the upcoming onyx logic program will be
focused on transcriptomics we will have
almost three months to discuss the
various aspects of RNA seek data
analysis and how this field of
bioinformatics continues to evolve this
technique has been refined over the
years and now is regularly used by many
scientists to perform in-depth analysis
of gene and isoform expression data the
year 2020 marks a 17 year mark since the
discovery of structure and function of
the DNA molecule it took almost 50 years
from that time to sequence the first
human genome but soon after the
technology developed at that time
started evolving rapidly by 2015 the
1000 genome project brought a
significant number of whole genome
sequences to the research community and
in 2018 over 100,000 whole genomes were
already sequenced today there is an ever
increasing number of genomic
transcriptomics proteomics and
metabolomics datasets available that
describe sub cellular processes with
highly detailed digital data the onyx
technologies are used to explore the
roles relationships and actions of the
various types of molecules that make up
the cells of an organism of onyx data
can be generated using next-generation
sequencing or what is also known as
high-throughput sequencing the data can
show detailed information about genomic
variants epigenomic regulation as well
as gene and isoform expression in this
program
we will focus on one type of this kind
of data transcriptomics this program
will cover analysis of gene expression
data with practical sessions and online
tutorials and anyone with a basic
knowledge of cell and molecular biology
will be able to conceptually understand
as well as practically apply standard
data analysis tools to process analyze
and interpret complex transcriptomics
data we will do so by leveraging regular
online webinars practical exercises and
online courses these resources provide a
broad and yet detailed overview of
processing statistical analysis machine
learning tools and single cell data
analysis techniques the course covers
methods expands on various terminologies
provides practical examples and offers
quizzes for self evaluation in addition
to online course
all participants will get access to
hands-on exercises in data sets for
practice these can be completed without
any coding using the analytical T bio
info platform that provides an
interactive learning experience the
platform is color coded to help
establish your logical connection
between theoretical aspects of data
analysis methods and the practical steps
needed to achieve a biologically
interpretive or result outputs are
offered as tables graphics and
interactive visualization helping users
understand the way data can be used to
study a biological phenomena a major
topic in analysis of transcriptomic data
is identification of differentially
expressed genes and isoforms while this
is a straightforward approach that
allows us to compare groups of samples
under different conditions several
considerations around data preparation
normalization and statistical
adjustments are going to be expanded in
this session the online session will
supplement information offered in the
transcriptomics 2 module that describes
a number of statistical techniques
typically used for simple and more
complex approaches to finding
differentially expressed genes we will
also discuss the properties of such
datasets where thousands of observations
about each sample contribute to noisy
and often misleading data such aspect of
log normal distribution and adjusted
p-values by accounting for false
discovery rate will be explained in
detail but the data offers more insight
than one can find with standard
techniques exploring data and
understanding as statistical properties
can help a spot technical variation that
can have unwanted effects on our
analysis some of the techniques are easy
to use and can be done in Excel or any
other type of table manipulation
software others require a more
streamlined approach many of these are
available on the analytical platform
that we will use once the data is
standardized and prepared we will learn
about working with identify genes to
arrive at a biological interpretation of
results ultimately it is not just about
the data and how to prepare it we want
to gain a biological understanding of
our project connecting the data elements
with their biological significance will
be a major focus of this program
oftentimes statistical tests do not
capture the granular
expression data in a given data set to
learn about methods that can handle
complexity that is typical for large
onyx datasets we have to learn about
additional methods of dimensionality
reduction data mining and classification
for example principal component analysis
can help us understand variability
between samples by analyzing all of our
data features we can use such
dimensionality reduction techniques to
get a better understanding into our data
set and visualize it so it's clear as a
result we will be able to study genes
how they describe samples in our data
set and how this correlates with
phenotypic information we have for
Biological or even clinical
interpretation but this is just one
example of data mining techniques that
can be used in this online program we
will learn about other methods including
various approaches to clustering network
analysis and others that can be used to
mine rich transcriptomic data for
meaningful patterns for example a
defined pattern of expression can be
linked to other players in a full
regulatory network affected by a certain
condition we will learn about these
types of situations and about dimensions
classes and features and all of this
will help us understand how these
machine learning algorithms can be
applied to offer biologically
interpretable results once we learn
about these data mining techniques and
explore the various patterns that seem
to be meaningful we can train a machine
learning model that will help us
classify new samples using patterns in
the data in the part of the program we
will learn about discriminant analysis
classification including linear
discriminant analysis support vector
machines and decision trees we will also
learn about the impact of feature
selection on interpretation of a
condition sampled from various data sets
to do that we will cover decision trees
and random forests to work with various
gene sets for classification these
methods are not always used in smaller
research projects however they have an
important application in pharmaceutical
R&D as well as many clinical
applications mastering these methods
will help you understand biomarker
discovery add patient stratification and
other issues that require predictive
modeling and feature selection but
ultimately we want to connect the data
with biology how can these genes Aiza
forms or their expression levels help
explain
mechanism of action explained the
process of deregulation of vital
cellular pathways or provide indication
that a gene or protein can be considered
as a target for a drug here we will
learn about various data sets that are
used to annotate our data and Link it to
functional properties found in a gene
ontology or pathway for example we will
learn to utilize gene set enrichment
analysis to find pathways or gene sets'
enriched with up or down regulated genes
of interest finally we will conclude the
program speaking about single cell
transcriptomics emerging since 2009 this
is a recent technology that continues to
evolve and diversified single cell
transcriptomics helped identify all
messenger rna's present in a single cell
unlike bulk RNA seek profiling we're
sequencing libraries are generated from
thousands of cells single cell RNA seek
technologies isolate single cells and
generate cell specific sequencing
libraries marking RNA content with a
cell specific molecular barcode this
amount of sparse data calls for
additional processing steps these
include special normalization approaches
filtering and quality control because
data can be informative but also very
noisy finally each participant will have
the opportunity to study how these
techniques are applied in the context of
a real project we prepared a number of
various examples that you can pick from
ranging from biomedical to agro
biological studies many of our past
participants had a chance to present
their analysis results in front of their
classmates or even conference poster
sessions and workshops we also receive
regular feedback about these programs
and the materials we collect have been
reviewed by faculty and students from
top US and international universities
this kind of feedback demonstrates that
the learning will be effective and even
transformational for many of you joining
this program we welcome you to join this
exciting program today register and
share this information with friends and
colleagues we're looking forward to
seeing you there
[Music]